pessoal boa tarde bom eu vou como eu vou
fechar vou começar já agradecendo
então hoje eu estou realizando um desejo
de muitos anos que era falar num telex e
nunca imaginei que na companhia do g8 de
gente tão legal
então parabéns a curadoria e
curiosamente eles me pediram para falar
sobre comunidades de inovação é até um
pouco paradoxal porque a maior parte da
minha carreira fiz na organização -
inovadora que você pode imaginar que são
os governos
eu quando estava no momento de escolha
de qual direção eu queria tomar da minha
vida eu me deparei desenhar uma carreira
que aparentemente apontava uma
estabilidade uma certa um certo conforto
que você encontre organizações mais
tradicionais e eu tive duas formações
bem tradicionais
então eu sou formado em direito eu sou
formado em administração pública e
depois eu fiz economia na mesma alma
mater do rádio então sou formado em
economia pela london school of economics
e curiosamente eu fui ao longo do tempo
desconstruindo toda essa visão que eu
tinha eu percebi que do direito eu
gostava mais da idéia de justiça do que
é de direito
eu percebi que na administração pública
eu gostava mais da ideia do público do
que da administração e da economia eu
percebi que eu gostava mais da inovação
do que a economia
então isso acabou criando boa parte do
que eu fui fazer da minha vida mas ao
longo desse processo eu fui percebendo
coisas que são justamente as raízes do
meu propósito é o meu propósito ele está
muito alinhado a servir ao público por
isso durante toda a minha carreira como
servidor público eu fui todos os dias
durante os dez anos que eu servir como
servidor público trabalhar muito movido
pela vontade de resolver problemas
complexos problemas públicos que de
alguma forma não são apenas do governo
mas sim
problemas que afetam a sociedade como um
todo e que assim sendo deveriam ser
também resolvidos pela sociedade como um
todo
o problema é que a gente vive numa
determinada visão em que o governo ele é
onipotente onisciente e onipresente e
para mim foi um processo muito longo
para desconstruir essa visão e entender
que na verdade o campo de jogo mudou e o
campo de jogo mudou justamente porque a
gente mudou a forma como acesso a
conhecimento e talvez a única forma de a
gente conseguir resolver problemas
públicos complexos é se a gente se
dedicar a criar o maior bem público que
é o conhecimento e esse conhecimento de
uma maneira também curiosa ele veio
mudando de mãos ao longo do tempo a
gente podia pensar que antes do
conhecimento estava totalmente
concentrado em organizações e atrás das
paredes dessas organizações como as
universidades mas existe conhecimento
sendo produzido há todo momento em todo
lugar muito tempo
se a gente pensar nas comunidades
tradicionais esses caras sabem como
ninguém resolver questões muito
complexas de medicina questões muito
complexas de governança social eles
estão fazendo isso há muito tempo mas
com a internet
boa parte disso mudou e as comunidades
que antes eram apenas físicas elas
voltaram para um outro ambiente que é o
ambiente digital e aí a gente começou a
ter comunidades que estão dedicadas a
resolver os problemas mais complexos e
problemas públicos complexos que a gente
enfrenta hoje comunidades que estão
ajudando a resolver por exemplo o
problema da mobilidade urbana
curiosamente em são paulo é essa
comunidade é uma das maiores do mundo já
que são paulo é a primeira cidade do
mundo o usuário lazy não é surpresa para
ninguém ou comunidade de desenvolvedores
que são aqueles caras que estão
entregando soluções de software soluções
e aplicações para mais de duas milhões
de pessoas ao redor do mundo
bikes em geral caras que estão de alguma
forma criando coisas físicas hardwares
abertos estão criando novas formas de
autenticação e verificação e criação de
confiança como é o caso do bloco tim mas
existem também aqueles que é a espécie
que eu mais gosto que são os
empreendedores
essa é uma espécie muito particular e
depois de uma trajetória de dez anos no
governo
hoje eu me vejo no desafio é justamente
de trabalhar com essa espécie de
construir uma comunidade de
empreendedores
mas engraçado a gente pensar que do
mesmo jeito que o conhecimento ele se
horizontalizar democratizou ele também
se espalhou
então a distribuição de seu redor do
mundo ela é total
a gente pode encontrar a comunidade de
empreendedores nos lugares mais
inesperados como o vale do silício a
gente pode encontrar comunidades
empreendedores nos lugares mais
inóspitos ou menos esperados com a
própria faixa de gaza
a coisa mais legal disso tudo é que
apesar da distribuição essa espécie é
única e eles se coordenam eles se
comunicam e eles se entendem e hoje eu
tenho o privilégio de liderar uma
iniciativa do google que existem seis
países do mundo
então o campo são paulo é um espaço para
empreendedores se conectarem aprenderem
e construírem as empresas que a gente
acredita que vão mudar o mundo
é interessante a gente falar de um
espaço físico em meio a toda essa
virtualização que eu mencionei mas é
importante e é fundamental que esses
empreendedores eles têm uma sala de
estar para conversar porque porque a
partir desse lugar é possível você
acessar o conhecimento de uma forma que
você jamais teve a possibilidade de
fazer em outros contextos
hoje e aí eu tenho o privilégio de
trabalhar muito próximo desses caras
eu não tenho dúvida que eu aprendo
semanalmente muito mais do que eu
aprendi em todas as minhas informações
seja na universidade seja no trabalho
seja na vida
o interessante
que mentes elas se encontram se conectam
ea benção esse ecossistema então existe
um efeito quase de atração natural que
faz com que pessoas que tenham essa
mesma vontade se encontrem e dividam a a
construção dessa jornada
mas o mais legal é justamente que nesse
campo de conhecimento
a diversidade é um aspecto extremamente
poderoso e quando a gente pensa no
brasil diversidade tem muitas conotações
diversidade pode ser geográfica pode ser
racial mas principalmente de ideias e é
isso que faz com que a gente avança na
inovação e é isso que faz com que a
gente tem esse tipo de característica em
todas essas comunidades
a gente está falando de um alinhamento
de propósito a proposta é uma palavra
que foi falada praticamente em todas as
apresentações desse bloco e o legal do
propósito é que esse alinhamento não é
necessariamente a gente enxergar a mesma
coisa mas a gente enxergar a mesma
direção então mais do que a gente
escrever um mapa como disse hoje 8 a
gente está buscando uma busca um lugar
em que a gente vai olhar ea gente vai
percorrer o caminho juntos buscando
entender quais as criações surge a
partir daí o segundo é confiança
ninguém faz nada sem confiança e
curiosamente a gente vive no brasil que
no último na última pesquisa mais da
américa latina sobre confiança entre os
países e as pessoas desses países a
gente figura no último lugar
ou seja a gente não confiar na gente
mesmo a gente não confia nas
organizações mais confiança é
combustível fundamental para as
inovações o terceiro transparência e
acho que transparência nunca foi tão
necessário transparência entre cidadãos
transparência transparência entre
membros de uma mesma comunidade
transparência nas relações
e isso tudo por fim queria o quarto
pilar que talvez seja o mais importante
que a sensação ou o sentimento de
pertencimento alguma coisa maior a
possibilidade de você fazer parte de
algo que vai ser definidor para aquele
grupo e para aquela geração
as criações que vão impactar o mundo
amanhã
elas estão sendo feitas hoje por essas
pessoas
o curioso é que a gente consegue
identificar claramente alguns valores e
esse pra mim é a liga é aquilo que vai
manter tudo isso acontecendo e crescendo
ao longo do tempo então é interessante a
gente pensar que uma pessoa como eu e
trabalhou mais de dez anos todos os dias
engravatado é possível ser sérios até
não é verdade
é possível fazer dinheiro sem fazer o
mal
se a gente focar nos usuários e nos
problemas que a gente está querendo
solucionar o resto tudo bem
a solução aparece e principalmente
rápido é muito melhor do que devagar
porque o tempo urge para a gente
solucionar aqueles problemas públicos
que estão afligindo a vida hoje e que
vão ser ainda mais importante serem
solucionados para o futuro mas eu
detesto quando eu tenho a sensação de
que eu tô pegando os convertidos e é
muito sedutor a gente cair nessa
nesse buraco está falando sempre para as
mesmas pessoas porque eu particularmente
acredito que a grande mudança que essas
comunidades podem fazer é justamente o
espalhamento disso para que a gente não
tenha mais pequenas comunidades de
inovação mas que a gente tem uma
sociedade voltada à inovação e aí sim eu
tenho certeza que a gente vai ter o
empoderamento que vai juntar
empreendedores governo inovadores para
criar soluções que vão mudar o mundo no
futuro então esse é o convite que eu
faço pra vocês sejam agentes que vão
espalhar a idéia de uma sociedade de
inovação
obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]